aquel lunes salió a hacer una caminata
en el bosque pero es una actividad que
está opositora la casa realiza cada vez
menos los fines de semana me quedo en
casa y puedo escuchar los disparos desde
ahí así que obviamente no salgo a
caminar este temor creció con la muerte
de King en diciembre de 2020 a pocos
kilómetros de la casa de odre
Morgan murió en su jardín mientras
cortaba leña fue asesinado por un
cazador que lo confundió con un jabalí
durante una cacería
en la prensa decían que todas las
medidas de seguridad habían sido
respetadas así que nos dijimos si es así
entonces hay un problema en las medidas
de seguridad
tras esta tragedia odre y tres amigas de
Morgan lanzaron una petición en línea
para exigir entre otras cosas que la
casa fuera prohibida los miércoles y los
domingos esta medida fue examinada por
el senado pero fue descartada por el
gobierno
Un día sin cacería no tendría ningún
impacto en el número de accidentes
porque el número de accidentes está
relacionado con el número de balas
disparadas
si no se casa el domingo se casará el
doble los sábados
prohibir la casa los domingos también
tendría consecuencias económicas esta
práctica genera más de 2.000 millones de
euros entre las medidas adoptadas para
hacer de la casa una actividad más
segura se encuentra una multa por cazar
bajo los efectos del alcohol el
endurecimiento de las penas en caso de
infracción y la creación una aplicación
de geolocalización nacional para mejorar
la cohabilitación entre cazadores y
excursionistas
ya utilizan una aplicación pero no creen
que ésta pueda hacerse obligatorio hay
sociedades de casa con gente bastante
mayor
y será complicado que implementen el uso
de la aplicación
la aplicación permite que los cazadores
indiquen sus zonas de casa para que los
excursionistas las eviten durante la
temporada pasada ocho personas perdieron
la vida en accidentes de casa
información para los ojeadores hay un
excursionista en la batida sin embargo
para los opositores a la casa estas
aplicaciones hacen que los
excursionistas sean los responsables de
su propia seguridad Cuando no son ellos
quienes representan un peligro en el
centro del debate también está la
biodiversidad la gran ausente del plan
referente a la casa representado por el
estado
solo
según el gobierno la sobrepoblación de
animales salvajes es una amenaza para la
fauna la flora y la actividad humana
cada año se destinan casi 100 millones
de euros a reparar los daños forestales
y agrícolas que estos causan los
cazadores serían la única forma
sostenible de regular las poblaciones de
animales para preservar la biodiversidad
nuestro papel no es exterminar nuestras
poblaciones todo lo contrario es
mantener un equilibrio todo el año
vigilamos la evolución de las
poblaciones
para Elis la casa es mucho más que un
pasatiempo es una forma de vida esta
mujer de 34 años señala que las
federaciones de casa están autorizadas
por el estado para proteger la
naturaleza ese día mataron a un Corzo
joven el animal es anillado con esta
etiqueta para su registro ya que la
especie está sujeta a cuotas tras ser
pesado y descuartizado
llevado a un cuarto frío antes de ser
consumidor
no vamos a matar a un animal para luego
tirarlo esa no es mi ética
para mí matar como lo hacemos nosotros
es un acto de responsabilidad
para comermelo Prefiero hacer eso que ir
a comprar carne que no sé de dónde viene
lejos del Mundo Salvaje un sinfín de
jaulas en estas imágenes obtenidas por
el activista contra la casa
se ven las presas apiñadas sus picos
cerrados con utensilios de plástico
algunos animales yacen sin vida estos
animales están destinados a la casa
según los cálculos del archivista
representan un tercio de los 22 millones
de animales que los cazadores matan cada
año la cría de animales de casa es un
modelo copiado de la creencia industrial
de aves de corral una vez que están en
la naturaleza están completamente
perdidos porque no saben cómo encontrar
son menos resistentes a las enfermedades
al clima de hecho la mayoría de ellos
mueren Antes de que los maten los
cazadores
las ong defensoras de los derechos de
los animales También tienen en la mira
ciertas técnicas de casa consideradas
crueles como la casa de montería un tipo
de casa que era del siglo XVI que
consiste en perseguir al animal a
caballo con una jauría hasta agotarlo
tradicionalmente es ejecutado con una
daga o un venable el colectivo abolamos
la casa de montería hoy lucha por
prohibir esta práctica
nuestro trabajo consiste en anticiparnos
situarnos a la entrada de la ciudad para
alertar a los habitantes y poder grabar
si hay algún desmán o comportamiento
ilegal por parte de los cazadores
mientras los cazadores persiguen al
animal los activistas persiguen a los
cazadores
el diálogo entre las dos partes parece
imposible Los practicantes de la casa de
montería dicen defender una tradición
francesa y cazar Por amor a los perros
aunque ese día ningún siervo fue
abachido para los opositores a la casa
el daño Ya está hecho
Aunque el ciervo logró escaparse quedó
sin aliento casi sin fuerzas los
animales tardan días en recuperarse
debido a la persecución de estas
personas en Francia hay 89 especies de
animales cuya casa está autorizada por
el estado una cifra récord a escala
europea no todas con sobrepoblación
algunas incluso están en peligro de
extinción